have already seen a black president
we've already seen a black first family
now we want to know what it is going to
mean
symbolism is not enough now is sub stuff
and if there's no substance then we've
gotten over the aura of the first now
those comments along with others at the
National Action Network we're dripping
with kind of grievance they led me to
pose this question yesterday today is
the anniversary of the assassination of
the Reverend Martin Luther King jr. I
was thinking like if he were alive today
I wonder what it think about such
dismissive comments and about a Democrat
party that believes it can regain power
by living in a constant state of
protests or racial hatred and denial now
for highlighting how the manufactured
outrage by some of the social justice
warriors is creating racial division and
hatred I was attacked
I just asking a question well kind of in
the response to proving my point aren't
they they're not interested in a real
conversation about improving the lives
of real people the state of the economy
for african-americans in this country
talking about criminal justice reform
school choice all the things that
conservatives love the life issue
instead they attempt to demonize anyone
who rejects divisive negative way of
thinking well they want to shut down
speech they don't believe in open
dialogue joining me now is a woman who
does they'll be the King niece of Martin
Luther King jr. alveta has the type of
stuff you're seeing from Jesse Jackson
and all the Democrats want after the
other after the other kind of bowing
down to his you know his identity over
the last few days you know I just were
just raised the question because it's so
negative it's almost like even Obama's
presidency was kind of dismissed by Al
Sharpton saying yeah he did some good
things but now it's on to the real work
isn't that amazing that al Sharpton
would say that he forgets many things
quickly I think he forgot that Martin
Luther King jr. was a prophet I think
Jesse Jackson forgot that too and in the
spirit of Jesus Christ it sounds like
socialism I guess to say feed the poor
and take care of the
but that's the perspective of Martin
Luther King in a prophetic voice not a
political voice yeah so some of your
relatives you guys were tweeting back
and each other intra family
conversations about this but you never
know what anyone would think it would be
fun to think what Thomas Jefferson would
think what would but it is and go back I
was watching a lot of his speeches
before the show and going back and
watching and he was you know he was
sounding more favorable in to socialism
and socialist ideals I want to read part
of one of his speeches I think we have
the full screen when he talked about
socialism is well this was a description
of him but dr. King was anti-war anti
capitalism and pro socialism he saw
capitalism as exploitative by nature an
economic structure that bred poverty and
injustice he spoke of his desire to
fundamentally change society several
times into a democratic form of
socialism which which the workers
collectively owned and direct profit
from the businesses in which they work
he saw capitalism as a method of
organization that produced an extremely
wealthy upper class but left huge
numbers in dire poverty and that was
Garrett Griffin's a book but his actual
speeches from King where he discussed
the need to fundamentally restructure
the economic system in the United States
so maybe you know the push towards
socialism kind of is in the tradition of
well exactly socialism because in
restructuring that system he would want
to see African Americans today owned
land owned property work contribute to
society so he would not necessarily have
supported just handouts without hand up
and equipping people to fish forever
rather than having a fish for a day so
that's why I say his socialism was more
remindful of Christ rather than a
political structural system but as far
as Perpetual protest he was sowing hope
seeds of hope one day this will end and
we'll all have something together that's
the Martin the King jr. that I actually
know what also working with people in
both parties which he knew you had to do
which I also think is sad it in in the
civil rights movement today it's
it's you didn't have a lot of Kirby
either our and if you're an
african-american everybody just insist
that you need to be a Democrat and
that's not really true Martin Luther
King jr. was an independent his dad
started out as a Republican but he was
an independent and people don't remember
that either and so that's why when
Sharpton just dismisses it and forgets
well we can't forget if we forget our
history will repeat the bad part but
then we'll forget to do the good part
over again alveta and also of course the
pro-life community you do so much great
work for that's all that's another
conversation that just isn't had civil
rights for the unborn had and I'm so
glad to see more and more being done and
we really need to end racism abortion
and infanticide from my perspective well
and that's a that's something that of
course as you call him daddy King yeah
in his court always pro-life daddy came
from life from birth until when he left
the planet supported life yeah no better
King so great to have you surfing causes
a family squabble